the transatlantic trade and investment
partnership the e u--'s hoped for trade
deal with united states which many
expect to transform the economies of
both sides is the biggest file for
Commissioner Cecilia Malstrom who
appeared before Emmy pees on the
international trade committee to explain
first principles and next steps
transparency she promised and a fair
deal for Europe in access to American
markets any piece de Medici hold to the
promises we welcome your initiative to
transparency that is very important but
I think we have to see it liver as well
trade in a way that we deal with trade
policy in the next five years will
determine whether the EU is seen to be
open for business we really need to see
action we really need to see something
delivered a breakthrough in efforts to
make the road safer of every year 27,000
people are killed on them a new
directive has been voted through
Parliament's Transport Committee making
it easier for authorities in a country
where an offence is committed to track
down the culprit the result it's hoped
that drivers will take far more care
hasta ahora los conductores que no son
del pais Oh Sal bien los turistas o los
que van de paso cetera por lo general no
tenían la unión europea lost our members
o te huna strumento para obligar lays a
pagar la Stanzione hacer frente a la San
Sione's en el caso de que no se les
Pereira inmediatamente
mikhail khodorkovsky the russian form
oligarchs jailed for a decade now
businessman and philanthropist call on
Emmy pees on the Foreign Affairs
Committee for strong support from the EU
for the opposition because he said
Russia's Neil totalitarian regime left
no room for it he also appealed for
targeted EU sanctions so ordinary people
weren't hit and was highly critical of
President Putin doest ayodhya breeze
nine years the Kremlin pravah deal with
shorter wouldna Tom stone [ __ ] is
reasonably Enya knowing his law private
cheloveka connection and shortly after
the EP TVs camera when asked what was
the purpose of his visit stoeber Europe
when I'm a Libra pesky yerba scope stop
animal estoy ACA y Putin Latin yet
Natasha one of the highlights of
Parliament's cultural calendar is
underway with the launch of ten days of
free screenings of the three shortlisted
lux prize films inside the building pavo
pavla kofsky was there to speak about
his film either a tale from Poland in
the 1950s of a woman about to take vows
as a nun who discovers she's of Jewish
origin it's definitely a European film
in every way it's black and white it's
depressing it's funny grud death the two
other films are French entry banda fee
and the slovene film class enemy the
prize encouraging european filmmaking
will be awarded during the plenary
session in strasburg later this month